it is supposed to be the hottest time of
the year in the philippines but a
tropical storm has battered many areas
in the eastern visayas region leaving
many towns cut off because of flood
waters and landslides in the province of
iloilo rescuers struggle to help
stranded residents to get them to nearby
shelters
in leyte volunteers are helping the
overwhelmed coast guards rescue the most
vulnerable
missions like these are often more
complicated given these communities are
in far-flung areas
in the town of baibai more than 14
bodies have been found after a landslide
and in the town of bunga rescue efforts
continue to be hampered by rain
as you all know this uh lenten season we
prepared for uh
the security measures heavy influx of
the passengers in the maritime safety
aspect of the traveling public we have
deployed around uh 200 specialized
water search and rescue personnel
uh trained to conduct uh search and
rescue operations even in
those
flooded areas
and
we have also deployed some of our rubber
boats and other
small floating assets to help in the
evacuation
power lines and communications are badly
damaged more than eight thousand people
are stranded and thousands have been
evacuated maggie known locally as
zagaton is the first storm to hit the
philippines this year and it came at the
start of easter week one of the
country's busiest travel periods at a
time too when the philippines has lifted
nearly all kovid 19 restrictions jamel
allendogen al jazeera manila